[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Ich habe euch vor Kurzem in meiner Story verraten,
dass ich auch dieses Jahr wieder
Plätzchenrezepte backen werde.
Eigentlich wollte ich keine backen, muss ich echt zugeben.
Aber von euch war es gewünscht.
Und ich habe jetzt mal alle meine Plätzchen,
die ich bereits auf dem Kanal gemacht habe,
mal zusammengefasst.
Und es sind tatsächlich, ich glaube, 40 oder 50 sogar.
Also, wenn ihr bei mir keine Plätzchenrezepte findet,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Trotzdem gibt es auch Plätzchen,
die ich noch nicht gemacht habe
und die ich einfach der Vollständigkeit halber machen will.
Deswegen gibt es in diesem Video gleich vier Rezepte.
Das sind vier ganz einfache Plätzchen.
Zum einen mache ich Traumstücke,
– die kennt fast jeder –
Vanillekipferl
und dann gibt es noch Waffelkekse,
also aus dem Waffeleisen.
Ich starte jetzt mal mit den Traumstückchen.
Denn das sind sozusagen die
– das ist die vereinfachte Version der Vanillekipferl.
Und zwar ist das Ganze ein Mürbeteig,
kein 1-2-3-, sondern ein 1-2-4-Mürbeteig.
Der ist nämlich richtig mürbe,
weniger süß
und den kann man noch richtig verfeinern.
[Musik]
Für den 1-2-4-Mürbeteig verwende ich
125 Gramm Zucker,
250 Gramm Butter,
500 Gramm Mehl,
– Weizen oder Dinkel –
fünf Eigelbe,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
eine Prise Salz,
eventuell etwas kaltes Wasser
und wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr gerne noch etwas Marzipan dazu geben.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach
verschiedene Geschmacksrichtungen.
Ihr müsst Marzipan nicht dazu nehmen,
– also das hier sind so die Basiszutaten –
ihr könnt es aber dazu nehmen.
Denn so schmecken die Traumstücke einfach nur nach Vanille
und so könnt ihr einfach noch mal
diesen Mandelgeschmack reinbringen
und sogar noch einen zusätzlichen Geschmack.
Also ich habe hier einmal
so ein Edelmarzipan mit groben Mandelstückchen.
Dann habe ich hier Salty Caramel,
Sanddorn Orange,
Tipsy Amaretto
oder auch Kirsche.
Da gibt es wirklich ganz viele verschiedene.
Und so könnt ihr noch mal
so einen Zusatzgeschmack mit reinbringen,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz eine Frage klären.
Und zwar fragen mich viele:
Wann nimmst du Puderzucker, wann nimmst du Zucker?
Im Prinzip könnt ihr bei Mürbeteig einfach Zucker benutzen.
Aber der Zucker braucht länger, um sich aufzulösen.
Also könnt ihr theoretisch immer bei Mürbeteig
Puderzucker benutzen, weil der sich
– weil der ist ja pulvrig, der löst sich besser auf.
Aber der Nachteil ist natürlich, Puderzucker ist teurer.
Denn der wird ja in so 250-Gramm-Päckchen verkauft
und ist einfach deutlich teurer als Zucker.
Was ihr aber machen könnt, ist Folgendes,
damit ihr einfach nicht eine Stunde warten müsst.
Ihr könnt auch einfach den Zucker selbst vermixen
mit einem Mixer.
Also es muss halt schon ein Hochleistungsmixer sein,
muss man dazusagen.
Und dann könnt ihr das selber machen.
Oder ihr benutzt einfach den Zucker
und lasst das Ganze im Kühlschrank eben gut ausruhen.
[Musik]
Ich bin Frau Holle. Ich habe Schnee gemacht.
Und dann kommt jetzt der Puderzucker in die Rührschüssel.
Und im Prinzip ist das Ganze ja einfach ein Mürbeteig.
Der sollte einfach schön kalt sein.
Also nicht zu lange kneten.
Falls ihr keine Küchenmaschine habt
oder kein Handrührgerät habt,
dann mit den Händen kurz verkneten,
aber wirklich nur kurz, bis sich alles verbunden hat.
Ich meine, ich stelle den Teig noch kalt,
aber das ist eigentlich so das Wichtigste.
Die Butter ist jetzt ein bisschen weicher,
also nicht ganz aus dem Kühlschrank.
Aber das macht nichts.
So verbindet sich alles besser
und ich stelle es ja gleich noch mal kühl.
Ich könnt jetzt auch gern erst Butter und Zucker verrühren.
Aber das braucht man wirklich nicht.
Wirklich alles schön zusammen.
Die Eigelbe mit rein.
Das Ganze kann man auch vegan zubereiten ohne Eigelb.
Dann könnt ihr gerne Apfelmus stattdessen nehmen
und natürlich vegane Butter.
Vanilleextrakt und Salz.
Ups.
Und vielleicht brauche ich Wasser, vielleicht aber auch nicht.
Ich muss mal einfach gucken.
Hier vielleicht noch als Tipp:
Für Mürbeteig nehme ich oftmals nicht den Knethaken,
– da dauert es mir zu lange –
sondern ich nehme so einen Flachrührer.
Jetzt kurz vermischen.
Ach, ja.
Nehmt einfach einen Spritzschutz bitte.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Also es sieht richtig bröselig aus,
aber, wenn ich ihn zusammendrücke,
bleibt er auch schön zusammen.
Ich würde jetzt hier, wenn ich kein Marzipan benutze,
noch einen Schluck Wasser dazu geben,
dass er einfach besser hält.
Aber ich brauche jetzt kein Wasser,
da ich Marzipan verwende.
[Musik]
Das gebe ich jetzt in kleinen Stückchen dazu.
Ihr könnt das Marzipan aber auch vorher einfrieren
und dann einfach dazu reiben.
Das geht auch.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt aus.
Richtig schön!
Falls ihr den übrigens vegan zubereitet
und auch diese tolle gelbe Farbe möchtet,
dann könnt ihr ein bisschen Kurkuma dazu geben.
Das ist eigentlich immer so der vegane Tipp,
weil das Eigelb natürlich einfach diese tolle Farbe liefert.
Jetzt hier kurz zusammenfassen.
Und dann abgedeckt in den Kühlschrank geben.
[Musik]
Und dann gibt es da auch einen Tipp,
nämlich, diesen Teig nicht als Kugel
in den Kühlschrank zu stellen.
So braucht er natürlich mehr Zeit, dass er kühlt.
Ihr nehmt einfach einen Teller
und drückt die Kugel einfach schön flach.
So kühlt es schneller.
Abdecken und kühl stellen.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist der Teig gut durchgekühlt.
Und ich nehme ihn direkt heraus.
[Musik]
Und ich forme ihn direkt zu einer 2 cm dicken Rolle.
Das geht hier auf der Backmatte auch ganz gut,
weil man es nämlich ablesen kann.
[Musik]
Und jetzt die Rolle wirklich schön gleichmäßig machen,
damit sie auch alle eine gleiche Backzeit haben.
Und jetzt einfach 3 cm große Stücke abschneiden.
[Musik]
Und dann direkt auf das Blech setzen.
So sind sie im Prinzip schon fertig,
also wirklich superschnell.
Was ich jetzt machen werde vor dem Backen:
Die kommen noch mal für 30 Minuten in den Kühlschrank
oder für 15 Minuten ins Gefrierfach.
So zerlaufen sie nämlich nicht beim Backen.
Und ihr könnt sie entweder so lassen
oder noch eine Gabel nehmen
und so ein bisschen eindrücken.
Dann habt ihr noch ein Muster drauf.
[Musik]
Oh! Mir kam eine Idee.
Man kann ja auch diese Fondantstempel nehmen
und dann
sogar sechs auf einen Schlag direkt einprägen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt schön im warmen Backofen,
im vorgeheizten Ofen backen.
Und ich habe jetzt mehrere Bleche.
Und bei Heißluft könnt ihr auch wirklich immer
mehrere Bleche Plätzchen gleichzeitig backen.
[Musik]
Diese Traumstücke sind jetzt wahrhaftig ein Traum!
Ach, die sehen schon schön aus.
Jetzt könnt ihr sie, wenn ihr möchtet,
mit Puderzucker bestreuen
oder noch besser süßer Schnee.
Denn auf der Oberfläche sollen sie jetzt hier nicht schmelzen.
Aber nur leicht,
dass man noch schön die Struktur durchsieht.
[Musik]
Beim Bestreuen könnt ihr es eigentlich auch so machen,
dass ihr sie vorher zusammenschiebt,
damit nicht so viel süßer Schnee verschwendet wird.
Der Tipp fiel mir natürlich erst ein,
als die Pistazien ins Spiel kamen.
Denn die sind teuer.
Also, wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr gern noch
so gemahlene Pistazien drübergeben.
Die haften jetzt nicht so gut,
aber ich finde es echt ganz hübsch
und es passt geschmacklich auch gut.
Die könnt ihr aber auch gerne schon einarbeiten.
Und dann sind die Traumstücke fertig
und es geht zum nächsten Rezept.
[Musik]
Die Traumstücke sind jetzt fertig.
Jetzt gibt es das zweite Rezept, nämlich die Vanillekipferl.
Und vielleicht für euch als Schnellbacktipp:
Also, wenn ich Plätzchen backe,
backe ich natürlich auch nicht eine Sorte am Tag,
sondern direkt eigentlich alle, die ich backen möchte.
Das heißt, ihr sucht euch zuerst die Rezepte raus.
Bei mir sind es meist immer so zwischen 20
und 30.
Okay, manchmal übertreibe ich es.
Ich finde, zehn sind auch okay.
Dann kauft ihr natürlich die Zutaten ein.
Und ich mache es dann so:
Ich nehme den Esstisch,
mache alles auf den Esstisch,
also alle Zutaten im Vorrat auf den Esstisch.
So habe ich alles griffbereit.
Ich habe hier hinten auch meine Schüsseln,
das heißt immer alles parat.
Und ich muss auch zugeben, ich mache es dann auch so,
dass ich dann einmal den Teig für alle vorbereite,
alles kühl stelle.
Und dann könnt ihr nämlich
mit der Zubereitung praktisch anfangen.
Also richtig so eine Plätzchenwerkstatt.
Und dann seid ihr an einem Tag richtig schnell durch.
Und bei den Schüsseln mache ich es auch so.
Den Mix zum Beispiel wasche ich nicht aus,
wenn gerade kein Kakao drin war
und sich die Geschmäcker eben nicht verbinden.
Oder auch hier bei der Schüssel.
Wenn ich weiß, es war jetzt nur ein Vanillemürbeteig,
kann ich natürlich auch den nächsten Teig drin zubereiten.
Also wirklich so effizient wie möglich.
Also jetzt gibt es Vanillekipferl.
Dafür verwende ich
125 Gramm Mehl,
100 Gramm Butter,
50 Gramm Mandeln,
– das sind so blanchierte, also geschälte –
40 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
Vanilleextrakt.
Und später brauche ich zum Bestäuben
noch etwas Puderzucker
und eine Vanilleschote.
Und da mache ich es jetzt ganz einfach so:
Die Mandeln werden jetzt mit dem Zucker kurz vermahlen.
Ihr könnt aber auch schon gemahlene
Mandeln kaufen natürlich.
[Musik]
Und der Grund, warum ich die jetzt mit dem Zucker vermahle,
ist folgender.
Wenn ich die Mandeln ganz alleine
in so einem Hochleistungsmixer mahle,
dann bekomme ich irgendwann Mandelmus raus.
Und so bleibt es schön trocken
und zermahlt sich auch schön klein.
Und jetzt wieder alle Zutaten hier reingeben
und kurz verbinden.
[Musik]
Also bei Vanillekipferl darf es auch mal mehr Vanille sein!
>> JOSH: Kommt eigentlich Kipferl davon,
weil man Vanille reinkippt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Spritzschutz.
Ach! Ich muss mich echt umgewöhnen.
Ich mache halt die Schüssel immer
– ich bin Rechtshänder
und ich mache die Schüssel immer so rein,
dass der Griff rechts ist.
Und jetzt muss ich mich umgewöhnen.
Ist okay.
Eigentlich gehört es so. So ist es richtig.
Und bitte benutzt einen Spritzschutz.
[Musik]
Also hier könnt ihr echt eine größere Menge machen.
Aber ich habe heute noch einiges vor.
Deswegen gibt es jetzt nur eine kleine Menge.
Ach, den brauche ich gar nicht kneten.
Den gebe ich jetzt auch direkt hier rein.
Schön kühlen.
Und, weil ich immer viele gleichzeitig backe,
mache ich es dann auch so,
dass ich mir den Namen der Plätzchen draufschreibe.
Denn ansonsten habt ihr einen Kühlschrank voller Teig
und wisst dann vielleicht am Ende nicht mehr,
wo es dazugehört.
Also immer schön dazu legen.
[Musik]
Vanillekipferl!
So.
Also hier knetet ihr den Teig jetzt ganz kurz durch.
Dann zu einer Rolle formen mit 4 cm Durchmesser.
[Musik]
Jetzt 2 cm dicke Scheiben abschneiden.
So werden sie gleich groß.
[Musik]
Dann formt ihr daraus kleine Kugeln.
Und ihr könnt auch hier die Hände gern leicht bemehlen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt formt ihr die zu kleinen Hörnchen.
Also...
Und die Enden nicht zu dünn machen.
Ungefähr zu einem
10 bis 12 cm langen Strang,
in der Mitte etwas dicker,
und dann zu einem Hörnchen formen.
Und die forme ich jetzt
und werde sie dann vor dem Backen
auch noch mal kühlen,
damit sie eben beim Backen ihre Form nicht verlieren.
[Musik]
Ab mit euch in den Kühlschrank!
Jetzt sind sie schön kalt.
Ab mit euch in den Backofen
bei 160°C Umluft oder Heißluft.
Falls ihr das nicht habt,
dann gerne Ober-/Unterhitze, dann 180°C.
Und natürlich könnt ihr hier einfach mehrere Bleche machen,
bei Heißluft viele zusammen backen.
Das ist so die Zeitersparnis.
[Musik]
Wenn die Vanillekipferl dann im Backofen sind,
könnt ihr schon mal den Puderzucker vorbereiten.
Und dafür verwende ich jetzt eine Vanilleschote.
Denn es sind Vanillekipferl
und da muss einfach Vanille ohne Ende rein!
Vanilleextrakt geht jetzt nicht, weil es flüssig ist.
Also hier die Vanilleschote einmal längs aufschneiden.
Dann mit der Messerrückseite das Mark auskratzen
und zum Puderzucker dazu geben.
Ich diesen Puderzucker dann in mein Einhandsieb.
Denn der muss ja sowieso gesiebt werden.
Und kurz verschließen.
Und dann schütteln,
damit sich die Vanilleschote eben schön verteilt
– also das Vanillemark.
Vielleicht komplett verschließen wäre nicht schlecht.
Vielleicht so schütteln,
damit es nicht schon mal unten rausgeht
aus dem Sieb.
So.
Und was ihr jetzt mit der übrigen Vanilleschote macht:
Die könnt ihr im Prinzip in euer Puderzuckergefäß geben
oder ins Zuckergefäß.
Ich gebe es hier einfach noch dazu.
Dann sich das noch ein bisschen intensivieren, das Aroma.
Und dann geht es gleich weiter,
sobald die Vanillekipferl gebacken sind.
Schöne Vanillekipferl!
Die auch wirklich nicht zu dunkel werden lassen.
Und jetzt ist ganz wichtig: Nicht wegbewegen!
Denn dann zerbrechen sie, da sehr mürbe.
Jetzt hier Puderzucker drauf.
Zack!
Ja, es sah nicht so elegant aus.
Aber schön dick mit Puderzucker bestreuen,
mit diesem Vanillepuderzucker.
Und sobald sie so etwa fünf Minuten abgekühlt sind,
verschiebe ich sie so ein bisschen,
damit auch die Unterseite praktisch mit Puderzucker voll ist.
Also ich finde, Vanillekipferl muss man
nicht unbedingt in Zucker wälzen.
Weil die zerbrechen sehr schnell.
So ist es echt einfacher.
[Musik]
Es schneit! Es schneit!
Kommt alle aus dem Haus!
Die Welt, die Welt sieht wie gepudert aus!
Es schneit! Es schneit!
Das müsst ihr alle sehen
– und riechen.
Die Welt, die Welt
wird niemals stillstehen.
So.
Schön!
Und der Überschuss, der wird ja später einfach so abgeklopft.
Vielleicht noch kurz als Tipp bei den Vanillekipferl:
Backt die wirklich recht am Anfang eurer Plätzchenproduktion.
Denn den überschüssigen Puderzucker,
den ihr hier praktisch runterklopft,
– ganz vorsichtig natürlich –
den könnt ihr dann zum Weiterbacken benutzen.
Also den muss man dann echt nicht wegschmeißen.
Nur so ein bisschen bleibt da dran haften
und der Überschuss, der kann dann weg.
[Musik]
Rezept Nummer drei sind Waffelkekse.
Ich nenne sie Freddie, die Strumwaffel.
Ja.
Das sind nämlich Kekse
– das ist ein All-in-Teig,
wo wirklich alles zusammengeschmissen wird.
Supereinfach, das bekommt jeder hin,
auch der Freddie.
Und dann werden die Kekse
in einem Waffeleisen ausgebacken!
Ich würde sagen, an dieser Stelle
nominiere ich Freddie zum Waffelkeksebacken.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Alles, was du dafür brauchst, ist ein Waffeleisen
und ein Eisportionierer.
Aber den solltest du schon haben von mir.
Viel Spaß!
Ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten.
Ich verwende dafür
160 Gramm braunen Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
25 Gramm Mandeln,
– die werden noch gemahlen –
120 Gramm Butter,
zwei Eier,
225 Gramm Mehl,
einen halben Teelöffel Backpulver
und zwei Teelöffel Spekulatiusgewürz.
Hier macht ihr es jetzt genauso.
Falls ihr keine gemahlenen Mandeln habt,
nehmt einfach ganze Mandeln
Ich mahle die immer selber.
Mit etwas Zucker
– da brauche ich jetzt nicht den ganzen Zucker –
kurz vermixen.
[Musik]
Und auch hier wieder ein All-in-Teig.
Das heißt, alle Zutaten in die Schüssel und kurz verrühren.
[Musik]
Der Teig ist schon fertig.
Und soll ich euch eins verraten?
Der muss nicht gekühlt werden.
Der wird direkt weiter gebacken.
Aber jetzt werde ich euch ganz schnell noch
Rezept vier verraten
– das leitet sich nämlich von Rezept drei ab –
und zwar Waffelkekse in Schokoladengeschmack.
[Musik]
Das heißt, hier habe ich schon alle Zutaten drin
und werde hier den Schokoladengeschmack
durch Kakaopulver
und Haselnüsse ergänzen.
Und da gebe ich noch Tonka Wonka mit dazu.
Ihr könnt auch eine Tonkabohne nehmen
und so ein bisschen was dazu mit reinreiben.
Aber ihr könnt auch einfach Tonka Wonka nehmen.
[Musik]
Also jetzt nehmt ihr einfach ein Waffeleisen,
fettet es ein bisschen.
Das ist ganz cool, weil man für diese Plätzchen
auch keinen Backofen braucht.
Also wirklich auch in jeder Studentenküche machbar,
wenn man ein Waffeleisen hat.
Und jetzt mit einem kleinen Eisportionierer,
damit es immer schön gleichmäßig ist,
hier Kugeln reinsetzen.
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken.
Weil das sind so richtig coole belgische Waffeln.
Die sind natürlich schön dick.
Bei den Keksen dürfte es auch dieser ganz normale
Waffel-Maker da sein, diese Herzwaffeln, diese dünnen.
Ich probiere es jetzt.
Ich hoffe, es klappt.
Wenn nicht, mache ich sie einfach größer
mit einem mittleren oder großen.
Ich glaube, ich brauche sie größer.
[Musik]
Okay, die sind etwas zu klein für mein Waffeleisen.
Ich werde jetzt einfach den großen Portionierer nehmen.
Und dann backe ich eben große Kekse.
Oh! Die riechen aber schon richtig gut.
Gut.
Also probiert am besten eine Kugel erst mal aus
bei eurem Waffeleisen.
Und dann könnt ihr die anderen machen.
[Musik]
Oh!
Hier riecht es so gut!
Guckt einmal. Oh, wie schön die jetzt sind!
Da könnte man so Tic-Tac-Toe drauf spielen.
Schon. Das könnte man schon.
Jetzt vorsichtig rausnehmen
und auf einem Abkühlgitter schön abkühlen lassen.
Und ihr müsst da im Prinzip nur darauf achten,
dass sie innen eben auch durch sind.
Oh.
Am besten die erste probieren
und die zweite.
[Musik]
So.
Und jetzt ist auch die Schokovariante fertig.
Und sobald jetzt alle meine Plätzchen fertig abgekühlt sind,
werden wir sie natürlich probieren.
Aber eigentlich schmecken Plätzchen
immer erst am nächsten Tag am besten
oder nach ein paar Tagen.
Aber wir machen heute schon eine Verkostung.
[Musik]
Also die Kekse sind jetzt fertig gebacken,
die Plätzchen.
Und jetzt brauche ich natürlich Keksverkoster.
Wer wäre da besser geeignet als Ripplinger und Palik,
die professionellen Plätzchenverkoster?
>> SARAH: Yay!
>> JOSH: So.
>> SARAH: Wir sind da.
>> JOSH: Da war kein Eichhörnchen.
>> SALLY: Ripplinger, du bist noch nicht ausgestattet.
>> JOSH: Ich habe es schon gedacht.
O Mann!
>> SARAH: Ich habe dir zu viele mitgebracht.
>> SALLY: Zeig ihm nicht das coole.
Der hat das lustige auf.
>> SARAH: Ach so.
Ach so.
>> JOSH: Worauf habe ich mich nur eingelassen?!
>> SALLY: Komm in unsere Mitte.
>> JOSH: Okay. Also dann
ja gerne.
>> SALLY: Also...
Okay, ihr wart dabei. Ihr wisst was es ist.
>> JOSH: Gerade wollte ich sagen:
"Was haben wir denn für Plätzchen?" und dann....
>> SARAH: Wir waren auch dabei.
>> JOSH: Ja, ich habe sie ja gedreht.
>> SALLY: Sie hat sie fotografiert.
Er hat sie gedreht.
Okay. Also...
>> SARAH: Sehen gut aus!
>> JOSH: Ich bin auf die Waffeln gespannt,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Gönnt euch.
>> JOSH: Weil...
>> SARAH: Warum?
>> SALLY: Oh ja!
>> JOSH: Weil ich die noch nie so gesehen habe,
so was Ähnliches.
Ich meine, Vanillekipferl kennt man ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Guckt mal, die härten schön aus.
>> JOSH: So.
>> SALLY: Aber bei Vanillekipferl gibt es Unterschiede.
Es gibt gute Vanillekipferl
>> SARAH: Aber ich will die.
>> SALLY: und es gibt schlechte.
>> JOSH: Deine sind ja natürlich gut.
>> SARAH: Deine sind die besten!
>> SALLY: Die guten sind die, die so richtig zerfallen,
so richtig mürbe, und die schlechten sind die, die hart sind.
>> JOSH: Mmh!
Voll lecker!
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Und erstaunlich keksig.
>> SALLY: Und Tonka.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Hm! Stimmt, da ist Tonka drin, gell?
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Ich esse Spekulatius.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Stimmt.
>> SALLY: Wow!
>> JOSH: Vorhin hatten wir es ja noch drüber, gell?
Eigentlich bin ich nicht so Spekulatiusfan,
aber
ja, okay,
>> SALLY: Seit diesem Video.
>> JOSH: überzeugt.
>> SALLY: Wow! Die... Wow! Schoko.
>> SARAH: Hierzu muss ich was sagen.
Ich habe es vorhin schon probiert.
>> SALLY: Ja, die Traumstücke.
>> SARAH: Du weißt schon, an was mich das erinnert?
>> SALLY: An was?
>> SARAH: An das Gebäck in der Türkei
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: beim Kaffee,
>> SARAH: weil das so weich ist.
Und weißt du, was dann war?
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Du hast gesagt: "Die Deutschen mögen das nicht.
>> SARAH: Weil das schmeckt wie Sand."
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Und dann habe ich...
Dann habe ich ihn probieren lassen und
>> SALLY: Ihm hat es nicht geschmeckt.
>> SARAH: ich habe gesagt: "Probier mal.
Das ist voll lecker."
Und er...
Und er so:
"Beiße ich gerade auf Sand rum?"
>> JOSH: Ja, genauso war es.
>> SARAH: Dann habe ich gesagt:
"Exakt das hat Sally auch gesagt über Deutsche."
>> SALLY: Es ist halt wirklich so.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil die türkischen Plätzchen,
die türkischen Kurabiye,
die sind nämlich ganz, ganz mürbe.
Also die machen sie wirklich so
und das heißt dann auch so "ağzında dağılan kurabiye",
also so, was im Munde...
>> SARAH: Ağzinda dalala azine.
>> SALLY: Die Plätzchen, die im Mund zerfallen.
Die zerfallen tatsächlich nicht so krass,
weil ich Marzipan drin habe.
Aber ohne Marzipan sind die auch richtig mürbe.
>> SARAH: Hast du das mal probiert? Das zerfällt aber voll.
>> SALLY: Ja, das zerfällt.
Aber die türkischen sind so richtig
– die werden zu Mehl im Mund.
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> JOSH: Sand.
Also
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> JOSH: die sind lecker vom Geschmack,
aber die Konsistenz ist nicht mein Fall.
>> SALLY: Traumhaft!
>> SARAH: Ich finde es mega!
Mir hat es in der Türkei schon megagut geschmeckt.
>> JOSH: Also die Waffeln sind der Hammer!
>> SALLY: Und wie sind die Vanille?
>> SARAH: Sehr gut!
>> JOSH: Die muss ich auch probieren.
>> SARAH: Oh, ich finde auch,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: die Waffeln sind
ein Träumchen.
>> SALLY: Und eins muss man dazu sagen:
>> JOSH: Mmh! Oh!
>> SALLY: Plätzchen schmecken am Folgetag
immer noch besser.
Das heißt,
einzeln, also nicht jedes einzelne, sondern jede Sorte für sich,
sortenrein verpacken.
Und dann sind Plätzchen auch mehrere Wochen haltbar.
Kühl und trocken aufbewahren.
Jetzt nicht im Kühlschrank,
aber vielleicht in einem kühlen Raum,
Abstellkammer, Garage,
– keine Ahnung –
Treppenhaus,
da, wo eben keinen Nachbarn
die Plätzchen wegklauen.
>> JOSH: Hoch genug für die Kinder.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Hm. Ela.
>> SALLY: Und dann könnt ihr euch gerne
weitere Rezeptideen direkt in meiner App anschauen,
auf meinem Blog oder auch auf YouTube in meiner Playlist.
Die App ist sozusagen
– und der Blog, das sind immer so die aktuellsten.
Also, wenn ich auch mal Rezepte von vor acht Jahren habe,
die ich mittlerweile einfacher mache
oder mit cooleren Zutaten,
dann tu ich es immer in der App praktisch optimieren
und sozusagen ausbessern.
Die alten Videos kann ich natürlich nicht verbessern,
die sind halt so.
Das ist halt meine Vergangenheit.
Aber ich lösche sie nicht raus.
>> JOSH: Nee. >> SARAH: Die sind süß.
>> SALLY: Das bleibt alles drin.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann
könnt ihr euch da gern inspirieren lassen.
Und ich habe auch ganz, ganz, ganz viele vegane Rezepte.
Im Prinzip schreibe ich alle Rezepte,
die ihr supereinfach vegan zubereiten könnt,
direkt mit in die vegane Kategorie.
Also könnt ihr auch als Veganer
ganz viele Plätzchen zubereiten.
So.
Your favorite?
>> SARAH: Hm.
Traumstücke.
>> SALLY: Die Traumstücke.
Your favorite?
>> JOSH: Die Waffeln.
>> SALLY: My favorite?
Auch die Waffel, die Schokowaffel.
>> SARAH: Echt?
>> JOSH: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber alles, alles.
>> SARAH: Hm, alles.
>> JOSH: Einfach alles. Ja.
>> SARAH: Das heißt, wir müssen morgen
alle noch mal essen,
weil es morgen dann noch besser ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Mh.
>> JOSH: Ach, schlimm...
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
Das ist halt voll die Weihnachtsbäckerei hier.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also...
>> SARAH: First World Problem.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ist so.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> JOSH: Tschüss!
[Musik]